une fois j'ai quelqu'un qui est venu qui
faisait une chasse au trésor qui voulait
absolument savoir sur la carte où je
pouvais trouver où était le trésor voilà
porter de demande un petit peu
particulière
bonjour je m'appelle Annabelle de
Villedieu et je suis médium clairvoyante
j'ai ce don depuis que je suis toute
petite et déjà enfant j'avais cette
hypersensibilité qui me permettait de
capter des informations de voir les
décédés en fait d'avoir des flashs et en
fait je suis comme ça depuis que je suis
enfant et c'est vrai quand j'étais
enfant c'était pas évident parce que je
suis arrivée dans un milieu très stricte
très dur avec une éducation très rigide
et j'étais absolument pas comprise par
rapport à ce qui m'a buté moi dans avec
ce don de médium clairvoyante au début
je savais pas ce qui m'arrivait
d'ailleurs je comprenais pas très bien
et à chaque fois qu'elle allait avoir
une personne qui partait ou un décès ou
un accident j'avais des idées
obsessionnelles qui arrivaient et ça se
répétait dans ma tête et je me disais
mais est-ce que c'est moi qui provoque
ça ou est-ce que qu'est-ce qui m'arrive
en fait et le jour où ça arrivait et ben
ça partait de moi et me mettait à
pleurer je me disais je veux pas que
vous mouriez enfin voilà c'est quelque
chose de très très fort qui m'habitait
et je compren sais pas et je me disais
est-ce que c'est moi qui engendre ça
est-ce que et voilà après j'ai compris
que j'avais quelque chose un
hypersensibilité qui était un petit peu
différente du comment et que j'avais ce
don en fait médiumnique qui m'habitait
mes parents ne comprenaient absolument
pas avec ce dont le médium c'était pas
du tout accepté et moi je viens d'un
milieu plutôt catholique aristocratique
avec des beaucoup de principes et du
coup c'était pas du tout accepté en
revanche m'amusais alors à 9 ans j'avais
déjà fait mon jeu de cartes que c'était
quelque chose qui était tellement à
l'intérieur de moi j'avais fait mon
petit jeu de cartes et je m'amusais à
faire des tirages avec mes cousins par
exemple et à leur dire des choses et
avoir des flashs alors quand on parle de
flash c'est vraiment pour moi en fait
j'ai de la clairvoyance c'est à dire que
je vais avoir des images quand je suis
en contact avec une personne sans que la
personne me dise quoi que ce soit ou
alors je peux avoir des images par
rapport à une photo ou par rapport à un
prénom c'est à dire qu'en fait j'ai
besoin d'un support ça peut être je me
balade dans un lieu parce que tout est
une question de mémoire les lieux
portent des mémoires également et dans
un lieu on peut aussi avoir des flashs
des images qui arrivent de des personnes
qui ont pu habiter le lieu des
événements qu'on puisse passer dans le
lieu quand je suis face à une personne
en effet on dirait que ben là je vais
avoir des images qui arrivent c'est
comme si je pouvais rentrer dans son
champ de conscience et avoir des
informations qui pour moi sont des
informations
au delà je dirais de l'espace-temps j'ai
animé la première émission de violence à
la télé donc c'était quand même il y a
14 ans
sauf qu'à 24 qui s'appelait medium et en
fait je n'avais rien du tout je n'avais
juste que la voix de la personne et moi
je demandais juste son prénom et son âge
juste pour me situer dans l'espace-temps
et juste à partir de cette information
et bien les images arrivent les flashs
arrivent les ressentis arrivent c'est
quelque chose qui vient m'habiter
profondément en fait et qui amène une
vision et j'ai fait pas mal d'études
j'ai fait des études supérieures je me
suis beaucoup cherché donc j'ai fait
j'ai commencé par faire véto parce que
j'adorais les animaux et je voulais
aller dans cette voie et puis après j'ai
bifurqué en pharmacie
aussi c'est j'ai fait ma première année
j'ai mon concours après j'ai fait une
deuxième année mais ça me plaisait pas
tellement et puis après j'ai refait un
caprice de physique-chimie du CAPES de
physique-chimie et je suis reparti sur
une école d'ingénieur voilà parce que
mon parcours a fait que
ça m'a emmené dans différentes univers
et puis on m'avait toujours dit que tu
seras jamais ingénieur alors du coup je
me suis dit j'y arriverai voilà c'est un
petit peu la provocation quelque part
donc du coup je suis allée dans cette
école d'ingénieur j'ai terminé major de
promotion quand même et je suis rentré
dans l'industrie renoutique en tant
qu'ingénieur et donc un univers en fait
qui ne correspondait absolument pas
j'étais pas très heureuse dans ce monde
puis pour moi était beaucoup trop
scientifique beaucoup trop terre-à-terre
mais j'ai compris en fait par la suite
que tout ce parcours de vie que j'ai pu
faire dans mes études m'a apporté
beaucoup d'éléments par rapport à la
compréhension justement de la physique
quantique de l'énergétique de tout ce
qui était la dimension
énergie etc et ça affirmer justement
d'avoir cette approche à la fois
spirituelle énergétique sensible et à la
fois cette approche
concrète et d'apporter en fait des
explications aussi à cet univers dans
lequel je suis et puis là 33 ans le
point zéro de ma vie et cet appel
intérieur qui me dit ok maintenant c'est
là il faut que tu y ailles et là j'ai
dit ok j'accepte de toute façon j'avais
pu c'était un peu le choix du nom choix
parce que finalement j'avais plus rien
j'ai fait mon premier salon de de
voyance à l'époque c'était à Cannes ça
remonte à 20 23 ans premier salon
premier article donc admis ce matin
prestation remarquée première émission
avec Ruquier première émission avec
Sophie Davant et après j'ai jamais fait
une démarche pour ça mais j'ai fait
toutes les chaînes de télé toutes les
émissions possibles et imaginables plein
de reportages je me suis même confrontée
en fait sur des reportages je savais pas
ce que j'allais faire mais j'ai dû faire
confiance à ton don quand on parle
parfois de la santé alors c'est vrai
qu'on n'est pas médecin mais moi je peux
capter moi je peux capter en tant que
médium certaines choses dans le corps
d'une personne et voir s'il peut y avoir
un problème de santé et parfois quand on
dit appair à la personne faites
attention surveiller peut-être au niveau
cardiaque sauvez au niveau pulmonaire
parce qu'ils peuvent avoir quelque chose
et ben on peut prévenir c'est à dire
qu'on pourrait on peut éviter quelque
chose
qui pourrait nous arriver si on n'avait
pas mis de la conscience dessus et j'ai
un de mes amis par exemple je n'arrêtais
pas lui dire il faut absolument que tu
arrêtes de fumer c'était comme ça parce
que je vois que il y a une embolie
pulmonaire et j'ai arrêté pas de lui
dire il faut vraiment que tu n'as pas
arrêté il a quand même plus une double
embolie pulmonaire donc il y a quand
même des choses qui sont intéressantes à
écouter parce que ça permet aussi nous
de pouvoir faire le nécessaire pour
transformer la médiumnité est une chose
mais on est aussi des êtres responsables
on a une part de responsabilité et le
médium il est pas là pour vous dire il
va vous arriver si ça ça et puis ça y
est on fait plus rien tout va se mettre
en place comme il a dit on a sa part de
responsabilité et on a un libre arbitre
et ça c'est important de l'entendre et
puis parfois il y a des personnes qui me
demandent des choses un petit peu voilà
ce que la bourse comment ils vont gagner
bon ça va marcher sur leur
investissement en bourse ou alors une
fois j'ai eu quelqu'un qui est venu qui
faisait une chasse au trésor qui voulait
absolument savoir sur la carte où je
pouvais trouver où était le trésor voilà
parfois il est de demande un petit peu
particulière après bon c'est
alors on peut arriver à avoir des
informations quand même mais
l'information c'est vraiment la personne
a besoin de la recevoir il va la
recevoir sinon pas forcément non plus en
fait en revanche je vais faire une
émission on m'avait demandé
par rapport au tiercé justement de
regarder
et c'est vrai que ça a été assez
percutant c'est vraiment bien réussi à
voir les chevaux sortants avec leur
personnalité voilà on peut aller quand
même assez loin dans ce qu'on voit mais
l'information aussi elle va être donnée
à la personne ou pas parfois on ne sait
pas toujours obligatoire que la personne
reçoivent une information si c'est pas
juste pour elle disons que ce qui est
juste pour la personne qui va recevoir
on va lui donner l'information si c'est
pas juste elle va pas la recevoir alors
par rapport à la 2023 donc ça va être
une année pour moi qui a pas une année
facile 2023 serait je vois une deuxième
partie de l'année très mouvementée donc
j'avais déjà fait des prédictions et
annoncer qui aurait beaucoup de
manifestations beaucoup de gens dans la
rue beaucoup de révoltes surtout sur la
deuxième partie à partir du printemps là
ça va être encore plus chaud pour moi
j'ai parlé aussi d'une problématique par
rapport à la volaille et une espèce de
grippe aviaire à nouveau qui va toucher
beaucoup
cet univers beaucoup de problèmes dans
l'agroalimentaire c'est pour moi cette
année un domaine qui va être très très
touché en tout cas avec beaucoup de
problématiques on a parlé de pénurie
mais oui oui je pense qu'il va y avoir
encore plus de pénurie qui vont
s'installer et beaucoup dans
l'environnement parce que j'ai beaucoup
de rêve en tout cas autour de
l'environnement et là c'est vrai que la
terre elle va beaucoup bouger je vois
beaucoup de tremblements de terre aussi
de scission je sais pas je vois la terre
qui bouge je vois beaucoup alors
peut-être pas ici mais en tout cas ça
peut être aussi sur l'Inde beaucoup de
choses qui vont bouger alors après on y
croit on n'y croit pas c'est sûr et je
pense qu'on a toujours peur de ce qu'on
ne connaît pas non plus et moi je dis
chacun le libre arbitre de penser ce
qu'il a envie de penser mais moi je peux
pas renier ce que je suis parce que même
si j'ai fait des études ingénieurs et
que je suis quelqu'un qui est besoin à
chaque fois quand même d'avoir des
preuves quelque part de ce que je
traverse je suis habité vraiment par
cette dimension par ce don depuis que je
suis enfant et je peux pas renier ça
donc pour moi il y a une vérité il y a
vraiment d'autres plans il y a vraiment
voilà
illuminité je ne peux pas la renier
parce que elle m'habite donc après c'est
une expérience de vie et je pense quand
on vit l'expérience on peut pas rogner
ce que nous sommes mais après moi
j'accepte parfaitement que il y a des
personnes qui n'y croient pas qui voilà
qui n'est pas envie d'y croire en tout
cas peut-être pour savoir peut-être
parce que ça leur fait peur et puis
voilà il y a pas de souci je pense que
chacun on est là où il en est et a le
droit d'avoir ses propres avis sur ce
qui